♪ That's Vinny and the Colonel
- Sup Colonel
- Ah nothing Vinny
just avoiding my fucking mother.
- Why's that?
- Make sure you go front to back
I have a date tonight.
- Ugh I hate that
you don't have arms.
- (burps loudly) you got a
weird fucking family dude.
(glass shattering)
- Awe come on man don't litter,
Gary the Gardener hates that.
(pinging)
- What the heck is this?
- What you got there Colonel?
- I don't know, I
think it's a thumb.
- Well is it yours?
- No.
- Then put it back, it's
none of our business.
- Dude we found a thumb
we should call the cops.
- Absolutely not Colonel.
- Why not?
- Colonel when I was nine
someone stole my bike
and you know what I did?
- [Colonel] What'd ya do Vinny?
- [Vinny] I called the cops
and you know what happened?
- You got your bike back?
- Nope they arrested my dad
turns out he'd actually
traded my bike for crack
but the point is we're
not calling the cops.
- Well then what should we do?
- We're gonna take
matters into our own hands
a little something I like
to call street justice.
- Alright okay okay
how do we do the street justice?
- Let's go see the one person
that knows everything that
happens in the neighborhood.
- [Together] Cat lady Carol
(hip hop beat)
- And that's how I learned
to soft boil an egg in my pussy.
- Uh that's great,
cat lady Carol but we're here
about the thumb, remember?
- Awe yes, yes of course
well I have been hearing
unsettling noises
coming from Dave's place
every Friday night.
(pinging)
- Today is Friday.
- And that means tonight
will be Friday night.
- Looks like we need to
check out Dave's place
(hip hop beat)
- Alright, that's Dave's place
let's check it out.
- This whole street
justice thing
seems like a lot of work Vinny
plus this just feels dangerous.
- What feels dangerous?
(suspenseful music)
- Oh nothing Dave,
didn't see you there.
- What are you guys
going outside of my place
it's Friday,
I don't like people hanging
outside my place on Friday.
- Why's that Dave?
What goes on on Fridays?
- Nothing you'd be
interested in seeing,
especially you Colonel.
- What, wait why me?
- It's a matter of your
own flesh and blood.
- What the fuck was that man,
did Dave just threaten
my flesh and blood?
- I don't know but Dave's
acting guilty as shit
and look.
(suspenseful tone)
- Is that blood?
Oh my god, shit.
Well that proves it Vinny,
Dave's a killer what
are we gonna do?
- We gotta catch Dave in the act
we gotta go in there.
- Oh fuck that dude,
I'm not going in
there, Dave's a killer.
- Fine I'll go in, you stay
out here an keep lookout
if anything shady goes
down, give me the signal.
- Alright well what's
the signal Vinny Is it
(speaking gibberish)
- No, just call my phone.
(hip hop music)
- Alright Dave,
where do you keep your
dirty little secrets?
- Oh no oh no Vinny Vinny
(speaking gibberish)
(keys in lock rattling)
- Shit
- How did he not get the signal?
Oh that's right oh
yeah I'm an idiot.
(numbers beeping)
- I have mozzarella
sticks for after,
but I accidentally dropped
the marinara sauce
outside earlier.
- That explains the stain.
- So do you guys wanna kick
it up a notch this week
(drill whirling)
- And that explains the noises.
- A drill-do Dave really?
- Yeah I thought we were
gonna have weird sex
drill-dos aren't weird.
- Alright, what did
you all have in mind?
- I'm up for anything,
as long as one of
you calls my dad
on speaker in the middle of it
the only way I can
cum is if I'm sure
I'm disappointing my father.
- Oh I know that makes you
gush like an unkinked hose
- What the fuck?
- Well alright then,
let the Friday night
fuck-fest commence.
(animals growling)
- Awe shit don't worry
Vinny help is on the way.
(police siren)
- Hey you
- Oh thank god
you're here officer
- What are you doing
staking out Dave's place
- There's something
going on inside.
- Yeah its Friday I
was here last week.
- You mean,
(pinging)
you're involved?
- Naw I wouldn't say involved,
it was more like a no strings
attached type of deal.
(phone ringing)
- [Man On Phone] Hello?
- Hi Dad
- [Man On Phone] God dammit
is it Friday again already?
- Vinny was right the cops
can't be trusted, you're dirty.
- Hey its 2017, sex is a canvas
that each person can
paint however they want
and there's nothing
dirty about that,
non consensual voyeurism
however is another story.
- What?
- Now put your hands
behind your back scum bag.
- Dave do you have any quilts
I don't think a towel
is gonna soak this up.
- Yeah just check in the closet.
- Ha ho man is
this not my closet?
I thought this was my closet
my mistake guys
I'll just be going.
- Vinny? What the hell
are you doing here?
- I, uh
- I invited him
- Mrs. Peppersnacks?
- Sorry I'm late guys,
just go along with it Vinny
I'll get you out of this.
I told Vinny he should
come and surprise you all,
I figured it would be a
nice treat for the group.
- Well I think we all
agree that's really hot.
- Well your timing
couldn't be more perfect
this is usually
when we take a break
and watch two people have slow
intimate sex with one another
- That won't be a
problem, will it Vinny?
- Why are you doing this?
- Just let this happen
(Jazz Melody)
- Hey man where have you been?
- I was in jail man,
you were right about
the cops by the way
I'm all for street justice.
- No I, I'm done
with street justice
I was, I was fucking wrong man.
- Oh well if cops aren't good
and street justice isn't good
what did we learn?
- Ugh I don't know man,
I guess stay away
from Dave's on Fridays
and maybe don't kiss
your mom for a while.
- What?
- Hey yous guys
- Hey it's Gary the gardener
what's up Gary the gardener?
- Have you seen my thumb I
cut my thumb with the shears
and now I can a
no pick the weeds.
- Hey we found a thumb.
- Yeah it's up my ass.
- Dude why's it up your ass?
- I hid it from the cops
when they were processing me
I didn't want them
to find the evidence.
- Evidence of what?
- You know for the
street justice.
- You really don't
understand street justice.
- My thumb is up your butt?
- Yeah and I fucking love it
- Like mother like son.
- What?
- Nothing.